on va revenir à ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée puisque 49-3 ça veut dire
possibilité pour les oppositions de
déposer des notions de censure et ce
n'est qu'à ce moment-là si elles sont
rejetées que le texte sera adopté
rexioti dit que les républicains ne
déposeront pas de motion de censure
qu'il en voteront pas sauf qu'on a
entendu hier certains députés les
républicains dire qu'il n'excluaient pas
dans vos têtes et qu'ils allaient les
regarder toutes c'est à dire compris
celle du rassemblement national qu'en
pensez-vous je pense que s'il vote une
motion de censure il se déshonoreront
voilà il n'y a pas d'autre mot il se
déshonoreront et j'ose espérer j'ose
espérer un d'abord qu'il ne soit pas
nombreux à penser pareil parce que ce
serait lamentable et deuxièmement que
ceux qui le font profiteront du week-end
pour essayer de se demander si il est
pas temps maintenant de d'arrêter
d'arrêter tout cela et et de se poser
pour comprendre ce que c'est la
dimension d'un échec qui vient s'ajouter
à des années et des années d'échec voilà
il y a un moment il faut il faut quand
même se poser et se demander à quoi ça
sert de faire de la politique pourquoi
on est là est-ce que c'est pour faire le
coup de la journée est-ce que c'est pour
faire le titre du journal de 20h ou
est-ce que c'est pour donner une marque
une dimension une profondeur à son
action au service du pays est-ce que
quand on aura 70 ans là à la retraite
pour le coup on sera fier de cette
comporter comme ça quand on en avait 35
ou 40 c'est ça le sujet et il y en a
aucun autre ce sera la même chose si il
vote la motion de l'iode qui sera une
motion transpartisanes ou si vous
apporte leur voix
Charles la médite Courson que je connais
par cœur qui était je crois même un des
doyen maintenant de l'assemblée qui a
été le chantre pendant des années de la
rigueur budgétaire avec lequel quand
j'étais mise du budget j'ai travaillé
j'ai que j'ai d'ailleurs souvent écouté
parce qu'il est très compétent
techniquement et le voilà devenu en fin
de carrière le gars qui va faire la
motion de censure contre la réforme des
retraites
ils sont devenus fous qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dis j'ai pas d'autres
explications ils sont devenus tous fous
et je reviens à ma question est-ce que
ce serait la même chose si les députés
lèrent votre motion liotte que s'il vote
s'ils apportent leur voix à la motion du
rassemblement ils sont pas ils sont pas
suicidaires les députés et les encore
que encore que enfin ceux qui veulent
voter l'émotion de censure déjà en soi
c'est c'est lamentable mais mais mais
même celle de Courson c'est tout aussi
lamentable qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise c'est quoi l'idée c'est que
ça suffit pas comme ça alors donc
imaginez une notion de censure qui soit
adoptée et que on se retrouve devant les
urnes on veut quoi que l'extrême droite
est 150 députés que l'extrême gauche en
est tout autant comparaise la France
pendant ce temps-là il y a une guerre en
Ukraine il y a une crise économique et
financière majeure non mais il faut 2
secondes voir la conséquence de ces
actes quand même
[Musique]